this is our exhibit on change blindness
change blindness was one of the most
exciting new phenomena that's been
studied in the last 10 20 years the
illusion it valves is actually the
illusion that we see everything in front
of us all at once and this demonstrates
that really we only see the things that
we're paying attention to what happens
in this exhibit is we have two different
pictures taken of similar street scenes
and one picture changes into the next
picture in 30 frames between each frame
there's a very short blink of one
thirtieth of a second and that blink is
enough to prevent you completely from
seeing the change from one picture to
the next if you take the blink out then
suddenly you notice every change as it
happens and it shows that just this very
short one thirtieth of a second blink is
driving the entire illusion or grab the
entire effect here this exhibit is
called bright black then it asks the
question what's the difference between
black and white which seems really
obvious but it's actually quite
paradoxical as you'll see in this we
started with just this one square up and
ask people what color that square is and
most people will say well obviously it's
white or light gray sometimes then we
put up another square next to it and
suddenly you see this new square is
white and the original square actually
is a darker shade of gray then we put up
even another square that's even lighter
people see this new square is white the
intermediate one is lighter gray and the
original one is an even darker shade of
gray finally we add an even wider square
at the end and everything shifts where
the new white square is white and the
one that was originally white is now
black I'm standing in our monochromatic
room this room is illuminated only by
low pressure sodium lights which are
special lights that emit all their
energy at just one wavelength because
color requires comparing the signal from
different wavelengths when everything is
lit by only one wavelength you can't see
any colors these are fully colored fake
flowers I'm wearing they probably look
colorless right now if I add white light
the white light can show that they
actually are colored but you can't see
that color at all under these lights
this exhibit
demonstrates the problem of subjective
expansion of time during unexpected
events and what happens is a very
repetitive event is happening once per
second and you build a certain clock
internally based on that but what an
unexpected event happens even though it
lasts entirely one second you perceive
it as lasting maybe one and a half to
two seconds so when the red ball comes
on and changes size or when the car
comes it has a crash it appears to last
longer if you watch the clock in the
corner you can monitor that everything
is on for just one second and off for
one second